folks dressing in red white and blue
trekking down to Henderson ready to
watch the city's fireworks show at the
Heritage Park for one woman this
Independence Day is unlike any others
it's the first one without her son
before following breaking news 8 news
now reporter Joshua peguero heard her
story
if I miss everything about them
everything just seeing them a smile
Cecilia Wilson's 34 year old son died
last October he served eight years in
the Army and him not being here on this
July 4th leaves a big hole in their
family he just wanted to serve the
country he just you know that's what he
was a person that really loved the
country love of the USA was a central
theme of Henderson's Independence Day
celebration a band serenaded the crowd
with country Tunes
[Music]
this event had all you'd expect food
face painting and a bubble making
machine
Jordan Roos attended with her two kids
mothers from the Philippines so having a
parent that came from somewhere just to
have a better life that's what this
country means to me families Park
themselves on the grass finding fun
things to do to pass a time into the
fireworks show a few told us the fourth
is a way for them to unite sparklers
we are a sparkler family so when we get
done here we have sparklers at home and
we'll be doing a lot of sparklers and
continuing the fun here but it's just
fabulous to have everybody here and
others say this is a chance to instill
the values embedded in our Constitution
and Bill of Rights to their kids you
know treat everyone equally and and just
just just spread love give give love and
grace to other people
now Joshua says one thing that was
unanimous among all the people he spoke
with is the love for this country and
for the freedoms it gives us